alors qu'il arrive à washington pour son
assermentation daube hayden s'apprête à
prendre les rênes de pays
mal en point face à lui une série de
crises graves et urgentes auxquelles
président élu a promis de s'attaquer en
priorité
voici donc les quatre défis qui se
dressent devant lui la pandémie d'abord
24 millions de cas déclarés le quart du
total mondial et surtout quatre cent
mille morts c'est plus grave que des
chiffres qui sont inquiétants c'est une
situation de catastrophe sanitaire avec
une perte totale de contrôle de la
pandémie aux états unis d'amérique
malgré son statut de grande puissance
mondiale
le pays semble totalement désorganisée
dans sa lutte contre le corona virus joe
biden va devoir y mettre de l'ordre
l'administration trope n'était pas
capable d'avoir un message santé public
unifié ce énormément de temps a été
perdu et donc la situation dont les
guérites extrêmement difficiles sont
plaints imposer le port du masque est
vacciné 100 millions d'américains en 100
jours avec la pandémie est venu
l'effondrement de l'économie
une croissance en berne pour la première
fois depuis 2009 et surtout deux fois
plus de chômeurs
joe biden promet d'abord d'aider les
ménages les plus touchés par la crise
une mesure phare un chèque de 2000 $ par
personne absolument nécessaire non pour
relancer l'économie mais pour empêcher
une catastrophe sociale
une mesure qui a un coût 1900 milliards
de dollars
une autre promesse augmenter le revenu
minimum à 15 de la mesure très efficace
pour réduire les inégalités dans
l'instant la structure économique et
surtout la structure des salaires
américain n'a pas mis à part john floyd
dzeko blick autant de noirs victimes de
policier blanc autant de symboles d'une
injustice raciale systémique
biden doit son élection en grande partie
au soutien des afro-américains sortie
voter comme jamais auparavant
ils attendent maintenant des gestes
concrets black and white
mais pour mettre en place toutes ces
mesures joe biden aura besoin de l'appui
du congrès du soutien aussi des
américains dans un défi majeur car dans
nos jobs lui a légué un pays
profondément divisé
un obstacle d'autant plus difficile à
surmonter que dans notre homme conserve
beaucoup d' influence au sein du parti
républicain
m mais tu as
le défi le plus urgent de joe biden sera
donc d'abord d'asseoir sa légitimité au
préalable essentielle dans une
démocratie qui vient d'être sérieusement
tu es beau relais ici jean françois
bélanger inde au canada
washington
[Musique]